if a hen and a half lay an egg and a  half in a day and a half how many eggs  would one hen lay in one day here's the  mistake most people make so we have 1.5  hens that lay 1.5 eggs in 1.5 days they  think that if you scale everything down  you would get one hen laying one egg in  one day this is wrong you need to solve  this problem by dimensional analysis the  number of hens by the number of days  multiplied by the rate is equal to the  number of eggs this means the rate is  equal to the number of eggs divided by  the number of hens times days so if 1.5  eggs produced by 1.5 hens multiplied by  1.5 days and that's a rate of two over  three eggs per hens days so if you  wanted to scale things down you're  scaling the number of hens by two-thirds  you're scaling the number of days by  two-thirds so you multiply these scaling  factors so you're scaling the number of  eggs by the square of two-thirds then  1.5 eggs multiplied by the square of  two-thirds is equal to two-thirds eggs